people dropping like flies around here
bullets flying all over our streets not
just in
chicago but also in new york also in
portland all over the place
right people are concerned about their
safety people are concerned about
even outside of america are adversaries
aggressing on us
china seems to be doing that and what
does aoc say she wants to do
she wants to defund military recruitment
she's hiding this in a defense spending
bill this is an amendment
to a defense spending bill she wants to
defund
recruiting in schools you know when
you're in high school and the military
recruiter comes in
it's like a rite of passage if you
happen to go to public school in america
she wants to get rid of that completely
she wants to borrow the military
from advertising or interacting with
people on twitch or any video game
esports or live streaming platform and
this is the statement she had she made
about it she put this out to defend
her indefensible egregious decision
whether through recruitment stations in
their lunchrooms or now through esports
teams children in low-income communities
are persistently targeted for enlistment
the military can for some provide a
rewarding career
but low-income americans are not being
given anywhere near the same information
or access to trade schools
college or other postgraduate
opportunities
now listen she's saying they're not
being given enough
information and that's why we need to
take away the information that we're
giving them about the military
the kids in these communities don't have
good opportunities so we need to take
away
one of the opportunities that they have
doesn't make a lot of sense
i mean even the language he uses the
military can for some
provide a rewarding career that's
outrageous
it's a it's an extraordinarily rewarding
career and it's a career for which
we are all grateful we civilians are all
very grateful because the military keeps
us safe
you know this was the one the one it
used to be in america the one aspect
of american politics that was beyond
partisan infighting was the military you
know the democrats would want to defund
the military itself
pull back defense spending republicans
would want to beef it up a little bit
more
but that's a little different than
what's happening here what aoc is saying
here
is we actually need to stop people from
joining the military
we need to minimize recruitment
because it's bad for people and the
military preys on low-income people
not the case by the way a lot of my
family a lot of my family
has served in the military and the the
picture that that is painted by
left-wing democrats is simply
not the case this is a great thing to
run on
you know the president trump has has
made this habit of campaigning on the
american flag in the fourth of july
and would you believe it the democrats
took the bait and now they oppose the
american flag and the fourth of july
and our founding fathers and apparently
now even joining the military
great thing great thing to run on great
great meme
great thing to put out there aoc not
just the military she wants to defund
recruitment for she also wants to defund
the police and this brings us back to
the chaos happening on our streets
because there's a political question
here which is who does this help
you know some people seem to think that
trump is allowing
the cities to burn down because it helps
him politically
these are democrat cities that shows the
effects of democrat policies
that's what the oakland mayor believes
the oakland mayor libby schaaf
told oakland residents she thinks that
the vandalism
helps trump she said vandalizing our
downtown gives donald trump the images
he wants
and the justification he seeks to send
federal troops into american cities
do you think donald trump wants to send
federal troops into american cities
of course not of are you insane
what what does he gain from sending the
federal troops in first of all if he did
gain don't you think he would have done
it
now months ago when all of this rioting
began
it's been going on for two months
wouldn't he have started it a little
sooner if it helped him
it doesn't help him at all because all
you need is one federal agent
discharging one round from their gun and
it's game over you're going to hear this
is kent state all over again
this is a fascist attack on the people
rising up and minorities and
blah blah blah whatever nonsense the
left is spouting
this is a terrible thing for president
trump now there is a little bit of a
political advantage
to people being able to see a difference
they say gosh i don't want my city
to to look like that like this democrat
run city but i'm not sure
people even put two and two together on
which party is managing those cities
in fact the images only really help
trump
if trump can fix the problem
the images help trump if trump can
effectively go in and and
fix the mess that the democrats have
made if if donald trump can't do that if
if donald trump just points over there
and says look at how those cities are
burning
re-elect me to save america that's not a
compelling argument because people are
going to look at him and say why do i
need to re-elect you you're the
president now
fix the problem now this is donald
trump's whole argument
the whole reason that people elected him
is because he went and he said i'm not a
regular politician
i don't know all the stupid stuff that
they always say i'm not all talk no
action
i build things i do things i'm not build
this country back up and do things here
that's that's what we like about the guy
he cuts through the bs
well if he can't get that done then
actually these scenes are going to hurt
him they've put him in a terrible
position
i have a great deal of sympathy for him
here but that's the key
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast wherever you listen
to podcasts